today on the best-selling children's
author matt walsh show leftists at st
louis university have gone to extreme
lengths to get my talk tonight canceled
i'll still be there tonight of course
but first we'll talk about what we've
learned from this whole absurd ordeal
also chris cuomo is suspended from cnn
yet zoom sex fiend jeffrey toobin
remains employed so how do they choose
who gets free passes over there who
doesn't we'll talk about that and just a
day after jack dorsey resigned as ceo of
twitter they've already made a major
move to suppress free speech on the
platform plus the jesse smilette trial
begins as new revelations emerge about
just how far he went in his um
race scam and a cnbc host calls for the
military to administer forced
vaccinations
i'll talk about all of that much more
today as a best-selling children's
author on the matt well show
well it's the holiday season and uh
that's a time for family and for
memories and that's why uh legacy box
this is a great time if you haven't used
legacy box yet or even if you have uh
this is a great time to think about
legacy box make sure to visit
legacybox.com and shop their cyber week
sale to take an unreal 65 off okay 65 i
don't think you're going to find a deal
like that ever again you got to take
advantage of this legacy box is the
simple and safe way to preserve your
irreplaceable family memories their
service couldn't be easier send in your
legacy box filled with old home movies
and photos and they will get to work
creating a digital collection stored on
a thumb drive dvd or the cloud in fact
come to think of it i have someone in my
life who still uses a vcr who maybe
could use legacy box it makes a great
gift as well plus with their cyber week
sale you can have everything preserved
at a fraction of the price why use
legacy box well because everything is
professionally digitized each item is
hand digitized by a team of over 200
trained technicians right here in the
usa their exclusive barcoded online
tracking system provides up to 12 email
updates along the way so you got to go
to legacy box legacy box cyber week sale
is here and they're giving our listeners
the best deal of the year visit legacy
box.com walsh ford incredible 65 off any
size legacy box that's legacy box.com
slash walsh for 65 off don't wait this
deal will not last legacybox.com
walsh so i must first of all applaud you
for uh listening to the show today
choosing to expose yourself to uh me and
my words and opinions and ideas opinions
are you know dangerous things you know
they're very dangerous
and i have lots of opinions as you
probably do too which makes me a very
dangerous man
and that's why my talk tonight at st
louis university has become such a
complicated
controversial uh hotly debated affair
i was invited on campus a catholic
campus i have to remind you again
to
you know speak words and convey ideas
all of which are words and ideas fully
in line with catholic teaching by the
way
everything should have followed rather
easily and simply from there you might
think
or you would think that if you're an
especially naive sort of person that's
not how it's gone so before we get to
the latest in this saga let's back up
and just review briefly
i was requested to come to slu and give
a speech on december 1st which is today
and the event was approved by the
administration
but then the leftist groups on campus
decided that this
cannot be allowed to happen right my
views especially the views that uh that
babies are people
and that women aren't men those two
views especially are so out of line so
outrageous so toxic they said that if if
they are allowed to be uttered on or
near the campus people might literally
die
so they started a petition
you probably remember to have my talk
canceled um that petition read in part
let's just review this again
conservative speakers have visited our
campus previously without issue
political discourse is valuable and
arguably necessary arguably necessary to
our college education but matt walsh is
not simply a conservative speaker he's a
threat to women the lgbtqi plus
community and racial minorities on
campus his twitter is one example of his
dangerous persona as you can read from
his social media matt walsh holds
extremely controversial and harmful
opinions for example he calls feminism
rotten at the core and one of the worst
things to ever happen to western
civilization he responds to his
dissenters by calling him stupid and
morally deranged he says gender theory
is by far the biggest threat in our
schools
these extreme statements uh
allow no room for healthy conversation
instead they promote dangerous
stereotypes okay
so they want healthy conversation and
their way to to have a healthy
conversation is to prevent one side of
that conversation from saying anything
dangerous harmful a threat
and this would be the theme
the other theme would be total abject
cowardice on the part of the leadership
at the school which has through every
step of the process
reviewed all of its options and
steadfastly consistently chosen the
wimpiest most pathetic most chicken path
possible and that's why it's responded
to the petition
originally it responded not by shutting
down the talk directly
but by imposing a number of onerous and
pointless and out of nowhere coveted
restrictions
um which would have turned the event
into an absurd display while preventing
many ticketed audience audience members
from actually attending keep in mind
that again the event was approved and uh
and then it was only after the fact that
after the petition that they came back
around and said oh by the way uh we just
remembered about covid and so we decided
that this and that restriction have to
be put in place for example they told me
that i would have to wear a mask while
speaking
to the audience and we'd have to check
vaccine cards
which wasn't going to happen
to get people in and we'd have to limit
attendance
among other requirements that um that
they invented just for my event but
after i started my own petition my own
competing petition to keep my talk on
campus and guarded 20 000
signatures in a day
a new solution arose the church on
campus volunteered
volunteered
to host the talk and they would host it
they said without any of the arbitrary
restrictions
you know
that were in place if i went somewhere
else so it seemed like everything had
worked out
that is until yesterday
on tuesday afternoon
300 faculty and staff published a quote
statement of solidarity
demanding that my talk be cancelled
so here's a sample of this lengthy
missive and of course statement of
solidarity it's no this is not a
statement of solidarity with the
catholic speaker who's trying to speak
on the catholic campus no it's
solidarity with the people who don't
want me to show up so here's what they
say impart
matt walsh is known for making degrading
statements about lgbtq plus identities
including pathologizing non-cis-gendered
individuals on multiple occasions
he also has made
denigrative remarks that negatively
stereotype other marginalized groups
such as on the basis of race this
rhetoric is dangerous yet part of a
pervasive cultural script that condones
bigotry to be upheld by the smokescreen
of free speech
free speech is a smoke screen
according to the 300 faculty and staff
on this campus
now this already sounds so on the nose
you know so much like a parody of woke
snowflakism that you i couldn't blame
you for thinking that i made that up
but i didn't i assure you this is very
much real and it gets worse
they continue
in his upcoming talk at slu matt walsh
plans on discussing the biological
ability to carry a pregnancy in order to
ostracize transgender women
well let me read that again in his
upcoming talk at slu matt walsh plans on
discussing the biological ability to
carry a pregnancy
in order to ostracize transgender women
so if you talk about biological science
on campus
that is a conspiracy to ostracize
transgender people that's what they're
saying um young transgender people face
physical violence and discrimination
they have a disproportionately higher
rate of attempted suicide compared to
cisgender folks and the life expectancy
of black transgender women is between 35
and 37 years due to compounded layers of
trauma
bringing a speaker on campus that
targets this already vulnerable
demographic is insensitive considering
we have already lost two slu students to
suicide since the start of the semester
additionally associating childbirth with
womanhood is also dangerous
associating childbirth with womanhood is
also dangerous
for cisgender women who are unable to
carry children have had one or more
miscarriages or stillbirths or do not
want to procreate
childbirth should not determine a
person's gender identity nor should it
delegitimize their womanhood doing so
can be very triggering and lead to
mental distress
again this this sounds made up it's not
now much here warren's comment i think
but let's focus for just a moment
on the mention of suicide on campus
this is where you see how these people
are not merely oversensitive
in fact i i it was always a mistake
to refer to this kind of stuff on
college campuses as as as sensitive
being sensitive
that's the last thing they are these
people are sociopaths sensitive
i mean being overly sensitive is a is a
problem because you're overly sensitive
but of all the flaws for a person to
have it's it's not the worst one
if you're truly like a sensitive person
truly sensitive person then that means
that you're you know maybe overly
empathetic right and you you can you
feel for other people and so that it
it's you know
that's the kind of thing that you have
to have in moderation and for some
people it's they haven't they have a
moderate amount of that but that's not
the worst thing in the world that's not
the case here though this is not an
overabundance of empathy
it's the opposite
and you see it by them using suicide
these are evil depraved people
because two students really did kill
themselves on slu campus
and and they as the administration and
the staff they think nothing of
exploiting those deaths
to score points against me
even though i of course had nothing to
do
with those suicides which i shouldn't
even have to say
those tragedies were in no way at all
remotely connected to my talk or me in
any way
there's also no indication as far as i'm
aware that these were trans people as
the letter seems to imply
so this is a gratuitous and shameless
effort to wield suicides as a cudgel
against me it's it's soulless and
disgusting
i would say they should feel ashamed but
i doubt they possess the capacity to
feel shame anyway
so uh then it goes on for a long time
and then finally the letter towards the
end says we want to be clear matt
walsh's viewpoints rhetoric and tactics
do not represent the perspective of the
undersigned slu faculty and staff we
denounce any narratives that perpetuate
insularity or impugn the dignity of the
individual including their vibrant and
intersectional identities
so there it is if you were worried that
these people might have written the
whole three paragraphs without using the
phrase intersectional identities
fear not you know if you're playing the
drinking game you could take a drink now
they fit that in at the very end
and this last bit of pressure from the
faculty and staff
apparently was too much for father dan
white who's the pastor of the church
that had offered to host the event
but had invited me to to speak at their
church
yesterday he sent this email to the
event organizers which was then
forwarded to me here's his email from
father dan white
at
slu
i need to meet with you today to discuss
the cancellation of our ballroom being
used as the venue for matt walsh's
lecture i apologize for making this last
minute but over the past two days i've
had the opportunity to view carefully
his facebook page and youtube page
his content regarding immigration
communities of color muslims and other
important topics is not in keeping with
who we are as a parish and as part of
the catholic church it is my fault for
not doing my due diligence diligence in
regards to his background before we
booked i'm sorry for that and for having
to make this decision at this late hour
sure you are father
you coward
now i would call him a coward and he is
a coward but i want to distract from the
fact that he is also a god-forsaken liar
uh it's not true that he just reviewed
my background over the last few days
i think we can really reasonably assume
that he knew who i was
and where i was coming from
when he originally agreed to have me
come talk
he didn't take any he didn't make any
new revelations about me or uncover any
deep dark secrets
he simply caved to the mob
and he also lies and defames me when he
says that uh my comments about
communities of color and muslims etc are
not in keeping with the catholic church
what
i mean what
muslims
when's the last time i even talked about
muslims
is it when i talk about ilhan omar
is that is that so criticizing ilhanom i
could only assume that's that's the
only time i can remember like in the
last year saying anything about muslims
and it was ilhan omar specifically not
muslims in fact the point of my comment
was that
criticizing ilhan omar is not a
criticism of muslims because she's she's
not a representative of the entire
religion she is herself and she herself
is a vile depraved
person so what precisely have i said on
any of those topics that falls out of
line with the catholic faith
he can't give an example because it
doesn't exist
it just doesn't exist
what have i even said on those topics
that's wrong
morally or factually
again he can't give an example
but he thinks nothing of throwing me to
the wolves lying you know and everything
in order to cater to the emotional
demands of a demented fearful
bullying mob
now
at the end of all this
um i'm still gonna give the talk
you know they put out a petition
they signed a statement
they kicked me out of two venues
put a whole bunch of red tape and all
kinds of other things in our way but i'm
still going to be there we secured a
third venue now and uh so i'll be there
tonight but still
words simply cannot express how pitiful
all of this has been
and also quite terrifying
because you know we we used to look at
all of this kind of thing
the way that college students are
coddled and protected from reality and
wrapped in swaddling clothes and rock to
sleep and shielded from any ideas or
opinions that might threaten to shake
them out of their stupor and we look we
used to look at all that we used to say
ah well you know the real world will
straighten them out
they're in for a wake-up call soon
enough
but the wake-up call has never really
come
i'm afraid to say
instead it was us who needed the wake-up
call
because they didn't have to adjust to
the real world instead the world
adjusted to them
i think we forgot that this is like an
entire generation of people who are
coming into society
and um and they're going to be running
things soon enough and so they they were
able to reshape society in their image
as as each successive generation is able
to do
we now live in a society that runs
itself according to these same rules
that you find on college campuses
the world didn't make them sane rather
they made the world crazy
or helped
there's a process in fairness that was
already underway
and that's all the more reason
why we can't bend to this madness
you know they call me dangerous
anybody else if you have opinions they
don't like then you're you're dangerous
we're all dangerous
well i uh i embrace that
in fact i don't i don't deny it
i don't think any of us should we yeah
sure i'm dangerous we should be
dangerous
we should be a danger we should be a
threat to this
obviously quite fragile world view that
they have constructed
it's very fragile it cannot withstand
any criticism i forget about criticism
it can't even it can't even withstand
discussion
so yeah we should be dangerous to that
and that's why i'll be there tonight
come hell or high water
now let's get to our five headlines
now a quick word from american financing
you know the home you're living in right
now can cost you less than it currently
does okay and we could all i think it's
something we could all use
lower monthly bills save money whatever
you can we could save a lot of money on
your home you can lower your payment and
save thousands long term you just have
to refinance to one of these incredibly
low mortgage rates and you should do it
now before they're gone these rates are
expected to rise in the new year you
can't afford to miss out it takes just a
10 minute call to american financing
america's home for home loans you'll
work with a salary-based mortgage
consultant someone who will guide you
through custom loan options that can
save you up to a thousand dollars a
month that's right a thousand dollars a
month you could be saving it's a
thousand dollars a month that you're
spending right now you don't have to be
spending and you don't have to reset
your loan to get those kinds of savings
you can choose any term 10 years and
over because you shouldn't pay interest
for years you don't need so this again
is all about saving money and it can be
done very very easily and quickly with
just a 10 minute phone call pre-qualify
for free at 866-5600
that's 866 569 4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net
and you know the worst thing by the way
about all this slu stuff is that there
is that really
let's not
lose sight of the fact that they're
trying to get a best-selling children's
author banned from campus what kind of
world are we living in when a
best-selling children's author can't
speak on a college campus that's my
question
and i am i
and i don't know if you heard i am in
fact a best-selling children's author uh
my book johnny the walrus which is uh on
sale right now at johnnywalrus.com
it did make its with with your help i
have to i have to thank you because we
we did get all the way to uh the number
three on amazon we got into the top five
into the top three actually among all
books on amazon
my book about johnny the trans walrus uh
easily the best-selling children's book
and one of the best-selling books in the
in the in the entire world right now on
amazon
and uh it sold so well that we actually
ran out we we sold out of our entire
first run our first stock of books we
sold out in less than a in less than a
day
um
and uh which is why if you go to amazon
right now or at least
the last i checked this morning you go
to amazon it'll say you know unavailable
that's not because amazon kicked us off
that still might happen i think it
probably will but no that's because we
actually literally ran out of books but
the good news is that you can go to
johnnywalrus.com
and you can uh you can reserve a copy
and then that will be shipped out to you
and lots of people are doing that so
again go to johnnywalrus.com and we're
getting new shipment in and soon you'll
be able to get on amazon again um until
until they do ban it um and uh we'll
we'll see now
the
the strategy here was
normally you know this would be the kind
of book that you would think amazon
would ban
but if you can if you can get it all the
way to the top and this and this just
shows how inconsistent and arbitrary the
rules are which which of course is no
revelation we know that but if we can
get it all the way to the top and make
it very visible then it's probably less
likely that they'll ban it as much as
they want to
because then everybody will notice when
they do it and it becomes a big story
and it's embarrassing for them and then
also it puts them in a position
if they were to ban it where amazon
would have to explain
why they banned this book and the
problem is for them is that the book
doesn't actually say anything about
transgender specifically so if they ban
a book about a kid pretending to be a
walrus
and said well it's anti-trans now
they're the ones drawing a connection
between walruses and trans people not me
and so that's the bind it puts them in
this was all if this was all part of the
plan okay
um
and uh and so far it's working well i
don't want to spike the football too
soon but we we did we were able to stay
on long enough which was only a day to
to sell out
um and that's why i mean you look at the
books they have banned
there was um the ryan t anderson's book
when harry became sally which is an
excellent book but it's it's
you know it's it's very
academic it's not it's not at all
inflammatory in the least bit
but they banned that because although
it's very successful book it like it
wasn't in the in the top 10 it had been
out for a while which is another thing
that made it so stupid that they banned
it like had been out for a while he'd
already done the promotion run on it and
it's just kind of like all books do
after you promote it and everything it's
just kind of like it's sitting there
somewhere on amazon and then they bid
hoping that nobody would notice so
that's where they that's what they
um
you know they tried to sort of pick off
the books
that uh that they think won't won't be
noticed as much when they do ban it so
again johnnywalrus.com and you can get
uh you can reserve your copy today okay
this is from cnn.com says a 15 year old
boy is in custody after three students
died and eight were injured in a
shooting tuesday afternoon at a high
school in oxford michigan the oxford
high school students killed were tate
meyer
hannah st julian madison baldwin
according to oakland county sheriff
michael bouchard eight others were shot
three are in critical condition with
gunshot wounds including a 14 year old
girls on a ventilator after having
surgery
terrible
story of course
not a lot is has been released we
haven't been told a lot about the
shooter in the case except that he's 15
year old boy that's that's i think all
we really know right now
um his
uh he was captured alive which is
somewhat rare for these school shootings
and
um and now he's in custody and
apparently according to reports his
parents have gotten him a lawyer and
they've said that he's not talking to
anybody
um now of course we will hear
after a case like this we're already
hearing
about uh about guns
you know how this is all the fault of
guns and so on
but waukesha already demonstrated that
taking guns away isn't going to stop
this kind of thing
even if we're not talking about waukesha
because the media's planning it didn't
happen it did happen
and it's a it's a very good
demonstration
of the terrible fact that when someone
gets it into their head that they want
to kill a bunch of people
there is as we talked about yesterday
there's really no tool that you can take
away from them preemptively
that will stop them
from from at least attempting to carry
it out
um also
one other thing one other of the of the
very few details we have about the
shooter is that apparently he stole his
dad's gun
which we would assume was purchased
legally so his dad legally had a gun and
then the kid took it and committed this
terrible crime
so what that means is that it was
already illegal for him to possess the
gun
and when he went into the school and did
what he did
everything about what he was doing
having the gun in the first place as a
15 year old
bringing it into a school
and then obviously shooting innocent
people all of that
is illegal and there are many laws
against all of that and then the
question becomes is there an additional
law that we could we could have passed
that would have prevented that
um
i don't think that there's an additional
gun law that could have passed
there there may have been other policies
like more security for the schools
that might have been helpful
but taking the gun with guns away i
don't i don't think would
what we should be talking about
as always is what drives a person to do
this
and
for school shooters in particular it
seems often and i don't know about this
case because we have so few
details but very often
with school shooters in particular it
seems that they're that they are not
driven by rage or even hate necessarily
but but even worse
by indifference to human life
you know total indifference
and that's why so often in these cases
you hear
from the survivors and they tell you the
ones that actually saw the shooter and
you have these haunting images of these
shooters
who uh so often were told they're sort
of casual and almost bored looking
as they as they go around killing people
it's kind of rare with these mass
shootings that we're told that the the
shooter was enraged you know spill
flecked kind of screaming and all that
kind of thing that's not normally that's
not the image that we're given we're
giving out someone just kind of casually
walking around shooting people totally
empty inside
total indifference to human life
and um
and that is a that is i believe that
that is an increasing problem in our
society
school shootings are still fortunately
relatively rare
but there are a lot of very empty
totally indifferent people walking
around
and whether there's guns or not horrible
things happen when you have a society
full of those kinds of people
all right next this from the new york
times says cnn star cnn anchor chris
cuomo was suspended and indefinitely by
the network on tuesday after new details
emerged about his efforts to assist his
brother andrew cuomo the former governor
of new york as he faced a cascade of
sexual harassment accusations that led
to the governor's resignation chris
coleman previously apologized for
advising andrew cuomo's senior political
aides but thousands of pages of evidence
released on monday by the new york
attorney general leticia james revealed
that the anchor's role had been more
intimate and involved than previously
known
cnn said in a statement on tuesday the
documents which we were not privy to
before their public release raised
serious questions when chris admitted to
us that he had offered advice to his
brother's staff
um
he broke our rules and we acknowledged
that publicly but we also appreciated
the unique position he was in and
understood his need to put family first
and job second however these documents
point to a greater level involvement in
his brother's efforts than we previously
knew as a result we have suspended chris
indefinitely pending further evaluation
okay well of course cnn deserves no
credit for this whatsoever they they
were backed into a corner and did this
because they had to also they're saying
they suspended him upon
upon further investigation that's also
what they said about uh jeffrey tube
after he masturbated on a zoom call
and then famously
he he was brought back into the full
so
we'll see if a similar thing happens
here if it doesn't that would be very
interesting
trying to sort through
at a place like cnn what exactly gets
you canned and what doesn't
if if jeffrey too if if chris cuomo is
never invited back
and his suspension becomes permanent yet
yet jeffrey two-bit is still there
then that raises a lot of questions
um
but one thing we know for sure as i have
to unfortunately remind you is that
chris cuomo will be replaced on air
whether permanently or not
and i suspect it will be permanent
and the reason i think it's permanent is
because they're going to find
just like they did in new york with his
brother
get rid of andrew cuomo he was bad
enough bring in kathy hawkins she's even
worse
crazier more far left more ideological
or at least more willing to be a puppet
for the far left in her state
um and they're going to do something
like that now with chris cuomo's slot on
cnn i mean the good news is that nobody
watches it you know nobody watched chris
como to begin with nobody will watch his
replacement but even so they're going to
find someone i guarantee you far more
obnoxious
it seems hard to believe but they will
someone far more obnoxious and certainly
far more um
farther to the left
than chris cuomo was they're going to
get my prediction is they're going to
get their own kind of joy read type
person maybe joy reid herself maybe who
knows
but it'll be somebody like that
that they have to replace uh chris cuomo
because as we know the rule here
is that
these institutions
as we've reviewed they they only ever go
to the left they never go to the right
they are on a sort of conveyor belt that
is moving perpetually to the left
and uh they never get rid of anybody
they never turn on their own
unless there's someone farther to the
left waiting in the wings that's the
only time they'll do it
all right what else we got here um
so let me i'm trying to pull this up
twitter
speaking of going
further to the left we know jack dorsey
stepped down from um
from his position as ceo of twitter and
that was another occasion where i had to
be the cynical guy and the the person
focusing on the
on the dark cloud within the silver
lining and uh say that you know
jack dorsey was
was probably not great for free speech
and all that kind of stuff
but it's going to get worse with him
gone and so within a day
here's the announcement from twitter
safety they published this yesterday on
twitter
it says sharing images is an important
part of folks's experience on twitter
people should have a choice in
determining whether or not a photo is
shared publicly to that end we are
expanding the scope of our private
information policy beginning today we
will not allow the sharing of private
media
such as images or videos of private
individuals without their consent
publishing people's private info is also
prohibited under the policy as is
threatening or incentivizing others to
do so
what does this mean well what it means
is
uh project veritas
is is gone you know this is
very specifically
targeted at project veritas they don't
say that but they might as well
uh and also it's not a coincidence that
this is happening number one right after
jack dorsey leaves but number two right
after the written house trial which did
not go the way that twitter obviously
wanted
and the red house trial was a story
about independent media really the uh
the heroes of that story were the
independent journalists who caught all
this on film if those cameras were not
there his written house's defense
attorney said this on fox after the
trial that uh kyle is very very grateful
that the cameras were there
um and that's one of the ways that you
know someone's innocent most of the time
is if something happens and they're
happy that it was caught on camera it's
a pretty good indication that they're
innocent
if that was not caught on camera if
those independent journalists with the
daily caller and other outlets had not
been there then kyle right now has gone
to jail for the rest of his life because
all we would have is the corporate media
version of events we would have a he
said he said
and as far as that goes rittenhouse was
outnumbered by antifa and blm they were
they were the primary ones there so we'd
have their story and we would have the
corporate media story really would be
the blm story as filtered through as
told by the corporate media and we would
have nothing else and then uh written
house is done
so twitter doesn't want that anymore and
now they've put this policy in place
which means no more of that no more
independent journalists capturing
inconvenient things on camera no more
project veritas capturing a lot of very
inconvenient things inconvenient for the
far left narrative on camera
um
but you read the policy and you think
well hold on a second
wouldn't this also apply to a lot of the
police videos that we've seen what about
uh george floyd derek chovin
didn't as far as far as i know didn't
consent for those videos to be out there
so
the next time there's a high-profile
police shooting
or somebody dies in police custody and
it's caught on camera
um
can can the police say hey i didn't
consent to this
well no of course not
because the rules are vague
and the ambiguity is the point
so what they're doing what twitter does
is they set the rules up
and then
you know they put it in the fine print
that it of course will be up to them to
decide who has violated these rules
and how we define all of these things
even something like privacy
is this a private individual is this a
private thing that's happening is it you
know how do we define that well it'll be
up to them
and that's the whole point so puts them
in a position where they can get rid of
project veritas and they can kick the
independent journalists off uh the
payroll i mean off of the um
they're not on the pair the corporate
media is more than payroll they could
kick the independent journalists off the
platform
uh but then they can you know they can
use their judgment and their discernment
to decide
when those rules do not apply and i
think we can guess
when that's going to happen all right
next the jesse smilette trial is
beginning this is from fox it says
justin jesse smallette because we're
getting more revelations about
what exactly smollette did
and what went into this scam
so here's the latest
justice millet was allegedly seen on
video conducting a dry run of his attack
the day before it took place
further lending credence to the
prosecution's claim that he orchestrated
the whole thing during opening arguments
on monday special prosecutor dan webb
told the jury that millett was upset
that a threatening hate letter that was
sent to the studio behind empire wasn't
taken seriously enough
and by the way that hate letter was
almost certainly written by smallet
himself it would seem so smollett sent a
hate letter to himself and nobody cared
and he got upset and so he said okay now
we got to take it one step further
and as a result webb is hoping to
convince the jury that the actor hired
brothers um
abimbola and uh ola
binjo
i don't even know why i why do i try
with names anymore we'll just call him
brothers a and o so he hired brothers a
and o to attack him one potentially
damning piece of evidence teased during
webb's opening argument was that there
is surveillance video showing smolette
and the two siblings who who he worked
with on empire doing a kind of dry run
of the attack in the area the day before
it allegedly took place they are not
sending their best with these hate
hoaxes they really are not thankfully
you know so it's always so obvious when
they are hoaxes
um
he was on camera he he
i'm trying to wrap my head around this
he knew the security cameras were there
and that's why he staged it there and
that's why he hot rather than simply not
involving anybody else and just saying
it happened to him that would have been
the smarter move by the way don't do it
on camera just like don't involve
anybody else
just claim that it happened
and nobody will be able to prove that it
didn't
yet when you involve other people and
you intentionally do it on camera now
you're providing evidence that can be
turned against you so he knew the
cameras were there
and yet he still showed up with those
brothers the day before to do a dry run
of the attack
my god just for fun can we play um i
have the video queued up this is just
for fun trip down memory lane as we get
to this trial let's play the video of
jesse smallad this was the uh the now
infamous interview
uh right after the supposed attack where
he's talking about the trauma that he
suffered and it's it's always a lot of
fun and pretty hilarious let's watch
that again
i heard
as i was crossing the intersection i
heard empire
and i don't answer to empire
on the empire
uh
and i didn't answer i kept walking and
then i heard
empire
so i turned around and i said did you
just say to me and i see
the uh attacker
uh masked
and
he said
this maggot country
punches me right in the face so i
punched that back
and then um we started tussling you know
it was very icy
and we ended up tussling by the stairs
fighting fighting fighting there was a
second person involved who was kicking
me in my back
and
then it just stopped
and
they ran off
and i saw where they ran
and the phone was in my pocket but it
had fallen out and it was sitting there
and my manager was still on the phone
so i picked up the phone and i said
brandon and his life's going on and i
said i was just jumped and i then i
looked down and i see that there's a
rope around my neck
so what we what you see in a video like
that we have what we have to remember
is number one
speaking of sociopaths like this is a so
it's it's funny that he's so stupid but
um
this is a sociopath
and also it's not just a hoax i think i
was using the word hoax before i i think
we should be careful about that because
hoax makes it seem
less serious than it is
hoaxes are bad enough
um this was not just a hoax this was a
scam this was a con
there was a piece i think of the
federalists making this point and um
and i i agree with it that hoax doesn't
exactly cover it this was a as
a con that he had worked out
very stupid yet very very intricate and
he was involving other people
and he had both a political ideological
and financial motive behind it
so the people saying oh why are they
going through a whole trial with this
these are misdemeanor charges
uh
no th this this is i think you should go
to jail for 10 years for this you should
go to jail for 20 years for this
that's not going to happen
i doubt he's going to serve any jail
time at all
but perpetrating a con like this
so that you can
fight
blackmail your employer into paying you
more money
and also you are exploiting
intentionally and trying to exacerbate
racial divisions
which is yet another reason
if for me i'd give him 20 years in jail
for this
all right um
what else do we got here let's check in
with jim cramer on cnbc
lord knows what happened if you didn't
partake but back then anyone who refused
to get vaccinated would get ratted out
immediately because we knew that person
could hurt other people the common wheel
was
a common will
now we're engaged in a similar struggle
with covid and eisenhower would be
aghast we have immunocompromised people
who are incubators for every variant to
come
walking around lawfully unvaccinated
that's psychotic
we have companies that have tried hard
to get people vaccinated now backing
down we have governors who want to be
president by grandstanding on a foolish
state's right issue the right to get
sick and get other people sick
so it's time to admit that we have to go
to war against covet require vaccination
universally have the military run it if
you don't want to get vaccinated you
better be ready to prove your
conscientious objector status in court
and even then you need to help in the
war effort by staying home until we
finally beat this thing
that's psychotic he says
uh first of all do people actually
listen to that people actually watch
that show
you could you could sit there for an
hour listening to that i can't imagine
that
speaking of psychotic how exactly does
this work having the military run the
vaccinations i saw someone suggest are
they are they uh like shooting the
needles out of a helicopter
it was
loading them into like
sniper rifles how does that work
but what we have to understand is these
people and this should be very obvious
by now um
these people of course do not care about
your freedom at all at all
they don't care about you and i don't
care about your health
for jim cramer over at cnbc this this is
all about him he's he's he is afraid
he is uh petrified
he's paralyzed in fear
and so he's willing to uh
burn the constitution
throw away all of your freedoms for his
sake
you know he doesn't even see you as a
human being i mean none of these people
do
he sees you as uh as
i think he even used the word incubator
i mean he he he sees you as an incubator
of disease he sees you as nothing but a
sort of like vessel of disease
that's to him that's what other people
are just especially like normal people
people who he doesn't consider to be on
his social
stratosphere
and so who cares just
lie you know all we should all be lined
up like dogs and uh and given our shots
because this is all about keeping him
safe of course
uh one other thing i wanted to show to
show you uh
this is a tweet that went viral from
someone who goes by the name professor
nalo
so let's read this it says
my students call me professor nehlo
because i prefer not to use mrs or mr in
my classroom i teach all subjects as a
first grade teacher but my favorite
moments are always when my students ask
about my queerness
she continues i was asked recently
during a podcast interview why i don't
use mrs or mr to refer to myself
and i asked her why i needed to she said
don't you think it'll be hard for
children to adjust
but the truth is it has never been
children that struggle with adjusting to
the complexities of human experience my
students are six to seven years old and
they're
steeped in the magic of curiosity my
students know about and have met my wife
at school they know i'm queer and the
turtles will call anybody out for
calling me mrs anything i told him my
story once and never needed to say it
again if only adults adjusted as quickly
and easily it may save many of our lives
uh and then she continues
from there
this is
another perfect example of of what i've
said before about this the non-binary
phenomenon
um
many different words you could use to
describe it but this is just narcissism
by another name this is a kind of like
sexualized narcissism
and we see that first and foremost
because she's a first grade teacher
calling herself
a professor
so that's
leaving aside mr and mrs is a non-binary
she goes by professor
teaching first grade students
which is which is something that like
literally anybody could teach first
graders
and you and if you have first graders
yourself you probably should teach them
yourself
rather than sending them to professor
nehlo so they can talk about her
queerness
this is uh this is narcissism this is
you always find that when they start
talking about why i don't identify with
the labels and you're always going to
hear as we do with the twitter thread
there about the complexity my my
personal
inner experience is so complex i'm such
an interesting
fascinating many layered individual
i mean you there the rest of you who
just
maybe you're fine settling for mr and
mrs he or he or she
but that doesn't work for me i i
the the english language itself cannot
properly describe me in all of my many
complexities because i'm such an
interesting and sophisticated person
that's really the point
somebody totally utterly obsessed with
themselves
and then you add in the sexual dynamic
of this and uh also grooming children at
the same time
talking to your kids about your
queerness
it should go without saying that's
that's not why we send uh
we don't send
kids to school to learn about the
personal lives of their teachers at all
and when i went to school i didn't know
anything about
any of my teachers i i knew i didn't i
didn't really even know their first
names
it always seemed weird to me that they
had first names
and there was always that weird
experience where you know you have your
like you're out at uh at the grocery
store and you see your chemistry teacher
or something walking down the aisle and
civilian clothes and it seems so weird
and out of place because this person
doesn't belong like they should just be
in a classroom that's how you think of
them
it's not about their personal
experiences
you're there to be taught the academic
subjects
so
really your students should should know
almost nothing about your personal life
but especially they should know nothing
about your sex life and especially when
they're first grade
so this is not teaching the word that we
would use for this is uh grooming just
to be clear
now let's get to the comment section
all right this is from blair says wow
such sage advice from someone with
absolutely no experience when lauren
beaubert got fed up with how things were
going here in colorado she did something
about it throwing her hat in the ring to
represent us in an increasingly purple
state wasn't easy she's fighting the
good fight for us sometimes it requires
she play the game
when the going gets tough would you
advise stand your ground or retreat to
more friendly confines like tennessee
okay um
so this is someone and not the only
comment upset with me for
taking lauren bobert to task for uh
apologizing to ilhan omar
and you say play the game yeah i
understand playing the game i i fully
understand that and as a politician you
have to play the game what i'm saying is
play it smart
just be smart about how you play the
game
um have a strategy
okay this is not a game of chance this
is not uh
this is not flipping a coin this isn't
dice this is this is uh this is this is
chess right this is a game of strategy
and so my question with lauren bobert is
what exactly was the strategy
in fact there are now more videos coming
out because the floodgates are open now
with the apology and so now they're even
more apparently beaubert has been going
around
at these fundraisers and making jokes
about ilhan omar the same joke about the
backpack and implying that she's a
terrorist and she's made this joke
multiple times and so now there's more
videos coming out and like is she going
to keep apologizing and she apologized
once or does that mean she has just keep
apologizing but the point is this this
was not like a spur of the moment
thing off the cuff you know we all have
moments like that
this is a joke that she used
multiple times like it's in her script
anyone in public speaking we all have
jokes we you know can kind of start with
and um
and those are not off the cuff and it
certainly isn't for her so
multiple times she's going out making
this joke with apparently no strategy in
place for what she would do
when eventually people notice that she's
made this joke and get upset about it no
strategy and so you're saying play the
game no she didn't play the game she got
played
is the problem
and what what experience do you mean
political experience so um
are you saying that i need to have
political experience in order to earn
the right to criticize politicians is
that what you're saying
blair
do you abide by that i mean are you a
politician have you ever criticized a
politician have you have you criticized
brandon up in the in the oval office
i bet you have yeah you have no
experience being a president
so don't don't don't don't don't play
that game
the whole uh
uh you don't have you you've never been
there i don't have to be there
that's not how it works with politicians
i don't have to earn the right or uh
there's no credentialism here i don't
have to flash my credentials in order in
order to criticize a politician
i pay their salaries that's why i get to
criticize them
and also by the way
i do have relevant experience more than
you do
because the discussion is how to deal
with public outrage that's the
discussion i deal with that all the time
i have a lot of experience i am very
experienced in that field i should have
a phd in that field i should have a phd
in the public outrage field okay
in fact i'll just say that i do i'm a
doctor i'm a doctor of outrage and uh
and so yeah in fact i do of outrage i do
have experience and that's why i think i
could give my advice here all right
um nick says uh matt walsh i'm a firm
believer in putting family first matt
walsh 10 minutes later makes fun of his
poor boomer mother for having a vcr to
probably relive her memories of matt
before he was such a sarcastic bastard
fair
very fair that's fair criticism
uh reed says you're always spot on but
you missed the one on the officer she
may not deserve jail time but an officer
who pulls the trigger on their weapon
and doesn't know the difference between
a taser and a pistol doesn't need to be
anywhere near a badge and that kind of
negligence warrants some kind of
punishment yeah i agree she shouldn't be
on the force so we can agree on that you
make a mistake of that kind
we're not going to put you back on the
force
and probably this is someone who uh
never should have been on the force to
begin with
but i don't think he put her in jail for
a mistake that she made in a life or
death situation that was created
by the other guy by dante wright
remember in the uh written house trial
where the prosecutors
were trying very hard to prove and they
failed obviously because it wasn't true
but they were trying to prove that
rittenhouse was the one who instigated
this violent altercation
because they knew that if ridden house
instigated it
if he's the one who created this violent
altercation
then um
he is not excused in using violent force
um
but he did
right it was it was it was rosenbaum
chasing
chasing him down
knowing that rittenhouse is armed he
rose bombs decides to chase down an
armed person and get into a physical
altercation with him meaning that
everything that happens from then on out
that's on rosenbaum he chose that
and i would say a very similar thing
with dante wright
um he has a wanted felon
could could have gone peacefully they
tried to take him in peacefully
they didn't go in their guns of blazing
they tried to just cuff him and bring
him to jail because that's their job
he's a wanted felon on a weapons charge
which stems from an armed robbery
what else are they gonna do let him go
and then he chose to escalate it and
turn it into a violent altercation and
by doing that he took his life into his
hands and um and then all the rest of it
is on him and so am i am i quote unquote
victim blaming in this case yeah
absolutely
um if the victim is the one who ends up
dead then yeah that that's on you uh
if you had not done that then you'd be
alive today
uh let's see pooh on your shoe great to
use name there says i can't wait to read
your book to my kids every night at
bedtime whispering long live sweet baby
gang as i tuck my twins into bed well
and you know i don't know if i mentioned
this but uh if you want to read this
book to your kids you can get it at
johnnythewalrus.com
and candace says the story about what
matt's wife did was actually really
heartwarming those little insights just
reveal a playfully loving relationship i
love that
what do you what when she locked me in
the room with the deadly spiders was
that that's heartwarming to you
or when she fat-shamed me which one of
those
things i don't find it heartwarming well
i feel so stupid that i i've forgotten
to mention this completely up until now
but uh i do have a new book out it's
called johnny the walrus and you can get
it johnnywalrus.com
it's already sold out we sold out of the
first run in uh in one day people this
what this tells me is two things it
tells me that um
people are tired of the left-wing
brainwashing in the when it comes to the
children's book genre they're very tired
of that and they're ready for something
different and for some sanity and common
sense which you could find in johnny the
walrus uh as well as humor and
everything else also maybe it tells you
that there is an untapped sort of
interest in walruses out in the public
that we didn't know about um either way
go to joiningthewalrus.com right now to
get your copy of uh my literary
masterpiece and uh one other thing i
want to tell you about if you haven't
already go check out our new comedy
series truth yeller hosted by comedian
and podcaster adam carolla over at
dailywire.com
watch that's
dailywire.comwatch watch each episode of
truth yeller adam invites a celebrity
guest to join him for an evening of
stand-up comedy improv interview all in
front of a masculist live audience the
first two episodes are available now
with the first episode starring none
other than jay leno adam's most recent
episode dropped on monday titled
unacceptable aromas on airplanes and
when to pour your beer into your lap in
this episode adam gets a little
offensive just a little bit you know uh
tells a lot of truth and sets the record
straight on no smoking laws rob riggle
the comedian from 21 jump street and
step brothers joins him to do a little
bit of stand up of his own and the live
audience loses it when adam gets gets an
improv request that he can't refuse this
is a great show
um you can watch yourself these are the
kinds of things we're doing with the
daily wire no one else is doing anything
like this so go to dailywire.com watch
and enjoy now let's get to our daily
cancellation
so there is no question that i use this
segment sometimes and i mean the whole
show sometimes to complain about
unpleasant personal experiences that i
have and i'm not defending
that choice i'm just confessing to it
what i want to talk about today is
somewhat in that vein i admit but i'd
like to extend the conversation beyond
my annoyance and identify the larger
themes that work here so uh with that in
mind um today i am canceling the the tsa
especially i'm canceling one particular
tsa agent who i encountered yesterday
though she is not unlike many other tsa
agents that i run across in my travels
very frequently so let's set the scene
here i was in um
at nashville national airport on our way
to dc
and i was in in in the most debasing and
humiliating stage of the debasing and
humiliating security process because
this is the stage where you stand at the
conveyor belt and you hurriedly remove
apparently dangerous items of clothing
like your shoes and your belt and your
jack and everything and to make this
process all the less efficient
different airports and different tsa
crews have different demands and
requirements during this stage sometimes
you're told to put everything into trays
sometimes you're supposed to put only
some things in trays and the rest
directly on the belt sometimes they want
laptops in a separate tray sometimes
they don't sometimes they tell you to
put everything together if you're
wearing a hat some agents will tell you
to take it off some will tell you to
keep it on
airport security has been unnecessarily
farmed out to the federal government
which means that if you didn't know
anything about the federal government
you might think that the one advantage
to having the federal government do
everything at all of these airports is
that there would at least be uniformity
from place to place
but if you do know something about the
federal government you know that the
only thing consistent and uniform about
it is that it is incompetent everywhere
and that's certainly the tsa what this
all means is that even you know some a
person someone who travels a lot like
myself
can still get tripped up from time to
time
can still
you know get some of the steps wrong
occasionally
but people who are not seasoned
travelers won't necessarily have any
idea what they're supposed to do
what item of clothing that's is supposed
to come off
what is supposed to stay on what goes in
what bin and so forth and this means
that the tsa agents have to explain it
to the passengers
now this is no doubt a tedious and
thankless job but it's quite literally
the job they signed up for it may be
dope boring but it's not difficult all
they have to do is stand there
and clear up any bin or clothing-related
confusions that may arise that's all
they have to do
and yet we find so often
not all the time but often that these
government workers who applied for this
job signed up for this job chose to do
this job are still put out about the
fact that they have to do the job
they're getting paid to do
they're impatient with confused
travelers
who are understandably sometimes
flustered by the fact that we're all
being treated like suspected criminals
just because we want to board a plane
the tsa agents are often irritated and
annoyed
and sometimes far beyond that yesterday
i encountered one who was in the latter
group so as i stood at the conveyor belt
shoeless and beltless the older woman in
front of me elderly woman uh she was
moving a little bit slower which is fine
fine with me anyway not with the agent
apparently the old woman hadn't removed
her jacket fast enough so the agent
started screaming
directly in the older woman's face i
mean
screaming directly in her face okay
so take off your outer garment take off
your outer garden screaming at her to
take off her clothes
nothing weird about that
and um i would have thought that that
her demeanor and approach was a little
aggressive even if she was like
performing cavity searches on new
inmates at a maximum security prison
but she wasn't dealing with inmates
she's dealing with an old woman who
simply wants to go through security and
go about her day and get on the plane
that's it so the lady eventually got her
jacket off and walked through um i
didn't really want to get into an
argument with a tsa agent but my desire
to not get involved in an argument with
tsa agent kind of is is overridden by my
total contempt for overbearing power
tripping government employees so i said
to the tsa agent as i was walking
through i said uh oh having a bad day
huh and she said gruffly busy day busy
day
and i said so does that mean that you
you don't have to treat people with
respect because you're busy
and she acted like she didn't hear what
i said so i said it again and at this
point she somewhat hilariously she took
her badge off and she waved it in my
face and she says you want to wear this
the truth is the last thing i would want
to do is wear that badge and get paid 11
an hour to scream at old ladies for not
taking their clothes off fast enough
but i told her no you know i don't want
to wear the badge
but the badge doesn't give her a pass
she should still treat people like human
beings anything really reasonable she
muttered something that i couldn't hear
and i just kept walking through now as i
said she's far from the first tsa agent
to behave this way
though she was perhaps a bit more
egregious than most
and this is what makes the whole tsa
experience so grading and soul-crushing
and dehumanizing first of all none of
these people should be there okay
there is no reason for the tsa to exist
it came into being in response to 9 11
and those who were born after 9 11
especially might not realize just how
and so you've lived in the world with
tsa your whole life you might not
realize how totally unnecessary all of
this is and gratuitous it is
um because 911 was not really a failure
of airport security the security failure
happened farther up the chain it was a
failure of intelligence a failure of the
fbi and the cia and other agencies that
should have found out about this plot
and stopped it but didn't um it's not
like the 911 hijackers made it on board
with guns and bombs
they took over the planes with box
cutters
but guess what box cutters were legal on
planes at the time the faa allowed
blades of four inches or less on planes
before 9 11. i know it sounds hard to
believe given that if you've lived in
this world where you can't even bring
nail clippers on planes but before 9 11
you could bring a knife on a plane it
was legal
um so but wherever the failures happened
it's certain that it was the government
that failed and yet the answer to the
government's failure is more power for
the government which failed
now as a consequence of that failure we
all must go through this embarrassing
security theater every time we want to
fly
so much of our lives of course have
become theater especially in the coveted
world government officials have become
like priests instructing us to perform
this or that ritual
whose practical utility is dubious at
best
the other thing that we find in these
kinds of experiences is that the old
adage about the corrupting influence of
power is true and that it doesn't really
have to be all that much power to
corrupt somebody
the woman standing by the conveyor belt
waving her badge around had power that
did not extend beyond the spot where she
was standing
so you are in her grip for about 20
seconds
as you stand by the x-ray machine taking
your shoes off
and she is gonna milk that 20 seconds
for everything it's worth
even the tiniest bit of power granted to
a person for the shortest amount of time
in the most limited capacity can still
go directly to their heads so how do you
end up with uh you know historically
someone like hitler or stalin
well that's easy to understand
if some human beings can become ruthless
tyrants because you gave them the power
to make strangers take their shoes off
at the airport imagine what that same
person might do
with an army at their disposal
tyrants come in all shapes and sizes and
you can find them anywhere i think is
important one other point
that i've been thinking about um as you
know at the airports not to beat a dead
horse but it has struck me that these
sorts of testy exchanges at airport
security have in my anecdotal experience
gotten worse in the last year or two
and you might theorize many different
reasons for that but i can't help but
wonder whether whether the masks
contribute to it for one thing they make
it more difficult for people to
understand each other and so now there's
more screaming almost by necessity and
it's also more frustrating you can't
understand what the hell anybody's
saying but also um they turn us all into
these faceless automatons
they lend a certain anonymity to
personal interactions
uh i wonder if this makes it easier for
people to treat each other as if they're
not human beings i wonder if that lady
the tsa agent at the airport screaming
directly in the face of an old woman
would she have done that if she could
see the woman's face maybe
i would also think it's harder to treat
people like that when you can see their
entire face
it's easier to treat them like they're
not human beings when you can't because
human beings have faces the masked
hordes that you encounter at airports do
not
tsa agents work all day in airports
interacting with shouting at a steady
stream of faceless strangers
and that has to have a psychological
effect after a while
which is not to let the tsa agent off
the hook not in the least which is why
she is canceled today and also of course
the entire tsa is canceled as well and
uh we will leave it there uh i'll
mention again johnnythewalrus.com to get
the book written by uh a best-selling
children's author you can go there again
johnnywalrus.com and uh i will also see
you tonight at slu and i'll talk to you
tomorrow godspeed
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo vadosky
the show is edited by ali hinkle our
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by cherokee heart and our
production coordinator is mckenna waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
john bickley here daley wire
editor-in-chief
wake up every morning with our new show
morning wire on today's episode the
trial of jesse smallett begins
the supreme court considers a case that
could overturn roe v wade
in new revelations from the hunter biden
laptop
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire